his implementations and execution of
stuff is severely lacking and I don't
think they're thought through straight
you lessons may sufficient quickly and I
think that's its Achilles heel
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine today we're asking a
question is Donald Trump a good leader
or not
Mark Cuban says no Robert Kiyosaki says
yes and I want to know what do you think
also if you want to know what Mark Cuban
and other successful entrepreneurs have
to say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below I've always been
passionate some people thought you know
it's a it's more OCD than anything else
I think his implementations and
execution of stuff is severely lacking
and I don't think they thought through
but I think the bigger overriding and
there's this brother there's 10 other
things I can go through on that list but
I think the bigger overriding problem is
in terms of leadership and management
and personal issues for him I don't
think he's a leader I think what people
tend to forget now is that now that he's
won the election he's the president he
is also the commander in chief and he's
also in charge of the federal government
that's four million plus employees
everything he says everything he does
when he does the press conference
yesterday he's not only talking to the
media he's not only talking to the
people who voted for him he's talking to
four million plus employees he's
speaking as the commander in chief to
the military and so when you do that you
have to come across as a leader you have
to show leadership qualities and in
order to show leadership qualities you
have to be able to admit a mistake right
because I think one of the reasons that
we're seeing leaks and so many problems
from the intelligence community and from
a staff for non intelligence issues you
know if the guy in charge or the woman
in charge does not admit or acknowledge
mistakes everybody that works for you
they see the mistake
they see the problem and if the top
person isn't accepting the
responsibility where's that
responsibility going to fall on one of
them and so knowing that they're gonna
get the blame
they're leaking to cya their own asses
right and so I think that that's a
symptom of his leadership lack of
leadership problem
so you said you know President Trump and
it seems like you knew him pretty well
what can you tell us about him well
first of all you know I wrote two books
together and the only other person that
shared the cover and we're supposed to
write the third book except today it's
time to write the third book she goes
I'm sorry I'm running for office I said
good luck now he is a fantastic man you
know look at the man through his
children his children are magnificent
and they're fantastically I mean they're
polish smart savvy well disciplined but
in dealing with Donald he straight
he listens makes additions quickly and I
think that's his Achilles heel
you know because bureaucrats all they
want is to keep their job they're not
here to get the job done so I feel for
my friend Donnell he's a great man he
has the same disease I have foot and
mouth or tweetIn mouth but you know and
I can't just I'm so politically
incorrect that that's what he is
it's unfortunate you know everybody said
well stop tweeting so I well it's Donald
and
people look at this one get to fullfil
or something he wrote he tweeted and the
same time he went to NATO and he said to
NATO pay up you guys are not paying your
bills then he went to Saudi Arabia and
says let's kick Isis's but you know
that's the kind of leader it is but the
press never covers that and what people
don't cover is and I'm not Republican or
Democrat I rather stay neutral
President Obama was the follow Hawaiian
or maybe from Argentina or whatever else
he could be from South America no he's
in Africa that's right but anyway he
gave Iran a hundred and fifty billion
dollars Iran is the biggest exporter of
terrorism in the world next to Qatar
then he released those Guantanamo guys
and he says I want you boys you be good
boys now and you promise not to be
terrorists anymore
oh yes President Obama we promise and
the alt run to Qatar and they were in
action that afternoon I mean and we're
after Trump for firing the FBI director
and we all know the FBI is a little
tainted also the CIA I mean I know a
little bit about the CIA because as a
murrain pilot I was recruited by them to
fly trucks I don't do drugs I'm pretty
straight so anyway our whole system is
suspect right now it's all these
bureaucrats and people with the hands of
the pot the question I asked all over
the world in this olive oil why does a
politician go into hafez poor and leave
rich how does that happen
that's corruption but nobody says
anything about that they get Trump for
some goofy thing you know so now I turn
the question over to you who do you
agree with Mark Cuban or Robert Kiyosaki
is Donald Trump a good leader or not
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and of reminder guys keep it civil
this is belief nation it's okay to
disagree with each other it's okay to
have different points of view but don't
get nasty don't call each other names
anybody who's disrespecting this
community will be banned from the
channel so let me hear your thoughts in
the comments below
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that passion not one
drop of my self-worth depends on Europe
it's something surreal and if you liked
this video check out the one we made on
is Tom Brady the greatest quarterback of
all time I think you'll like it
the link is right there next to me
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you watch Tom Brady there's no way
he backs down from challenge
I hate Tom Brady I want to be the best I
can be